cosa ma non pensavo mai la partenza così
ragazzi sella a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a saluto con i migranti hanno
fatto saggi un simulator 2
sia io che presto anche un soldo
portiamo sul nostro dei nostri canali in
coop perché la cosa bella di stato
inserito due e che è in corso e la cosa
bellissima
e tra l'altro hanno fatto un cambiamento
estremo adesso non è più che tu stai
ferma e file operazioni ma ti puoi
muovere fare le cose tipo salutare
continuiamo perché il socialista che
ferisce anche un'altra operazione
andiamo su loadout che non trovano però
è un'altra operazione per partire
bisogna entrare in questi tubi e non ho
capito il senso di questa cosa però
andiamo e più all operazione perché poi
sono palesemente non lo so e tutti del
sesso e con tracce per gli altri due
entri nello scarico noto beh beh è
comunque realistico l'obiettivo raga è
sempre salvare bob perché bob è sempre
personaggio di un simulator negli anni è
rimasto sempre lui poi è un cristiano
dobbiamo staccarli la la gamba destra
l'abbraccio adesso l'intestino largo
grasso bra bra problema ragazzi visto
gioco e che tu vuoi staccare già l'aria
ma non ho fatto niente non ho fatto
niente
metti la siringa siringa veloce lo so se
in crescita si incazza effetto ragazzi
il braccio è quello giù e vabbè non fa
niente tanto non se ne accorge nessuno
perrella strozzato ma cosa che ok se
relazionato con la pfeiffer opera
cametti la siringa per favore stai fa lo
aspetta facciamo che abbiamo già
smarrimento che lo ferì ti prego vabbè
allora che facciamo il punto di vista
col quale mi devo staccarlo sì quello
questo questo qua il premio nobel
criminale tirando via
ma chi se ne frega staccata la siringa
dove non ho fatto ho fatto no non fa
niente tanto non se ne accorge nessuno
tipo così ma è un altro intestino a me
sembra una pianta adesso me lo metto al
posto delle gambe e la testa anche scusa
ma come l'ho colpito con un intestino
attaccano i pagamenti a testa per l'amor
del cielo ai signori nazzari macchina
cava le 16 la cosa adesso vi adesso mi
diceva gesù era morto lista gli ho
staccato una gamba e tu per fermare
l'emorragia li hai fatto è stato legato
al successo non l'avevi niente ma no
data vi spiego l'abbiamo fatto ragazze
quindi dovremo dare il prezzo giusto
vabbè ho capito mica solo perché un
sinistro ma questa che ne frega lui ha
tanto ieri all essere intesa solo grossa
posso prendere qua qua c'è un altro
braccio
tieni prova questo abbiamo perso
proviamo mentre imbarazzante andato
quello di sicura che pare che funziona
si muore il paziente figura ok
eccolo mai ceiling ma cosa va bene
perfetto
completata e sconti resca gran livello
che la cosa vedo ci siamo gli stessi che
sono brava perché mi è piaciuto comunque
siamo stati bravi tranne che sia in
sagra non è così per si va a casa
vabbè ma si fa così anch'io ho visto
fare in ostetrica stesse cose questo
mentre fanno impartì comunque a
proposito volevo dire che questo gioco
non solo è così ma anche il fast
battaglia tipo fort nike quindi tu
quando fai le cose poi sbloccarti invece
così è personaggio adesso mi sa che
abbiamo piani un'altra
opera mini per allora cos'è questa roba
bottone prima di tutto il bottino fuori
poi schiaccia il tasto ok e bomba
arrivato io c'ho il braccio così allora
son trovato qualcosa ma dietro e fermi
da oltre ato qualcosa fermi tutti
c'è una ventola come stai inventato non
lo so ha diviso le riprese a me la gamba
dice re place ed è giusto guardatelo in
lei che è giusto dobbiamo togliergli il
polmone né il cuore alla strada col
cuore
io non faccio io no fate voi ma non so
neanche quale lo stomaco fallo tu fallo
turno imprendo le cose prima di tutto
bisogna soltanto io
porca miseria soltanto per sbaglio
questo è l'intesa non c'entrava niente
aspetta che rimettono non c'entrava
nulla questo è quello un polmone
prendono però senato mette arrivi ancora
giusta dove la siringa la faccio io
perché si muore
eli appoggiato nel tavolo con gli più
cose possibili che io viva la siringa
che aspettava veloce però è stato
incastrato uccidendo la smetti di sangue
fair e metti glielo addio sta morendo
termine fatto il sangue non lo so se
come sta morendo prova sembra stabile va
bene di fare l'altra siringa di saper
fare una diagnosi viene a vedere
ma credo che la testa non sia suo posto
serve adesso a posto ma chi è che butta
giù computer bene al contrario ma non si
vede niente
vabbè ma chi se ne frega raga tanto
abbiamo capito sono il cuore e lo stollo
che arriva da attuare e prima quale va
bene aspetta che faccio io se vuoi
partito preso o non sappiamo se sta
morendo nel dubbio è una sinigaglia
farei non so dovrei prendere altre alle
imprese le associazioni che abbiamo per
tu con il possibile questa per morire
tipo in tempo zero ma fa niente
ok ma anche secondo me nella stanzetta
dei fusibili qualità questa questa
questa voci sulle stringhe per
l'emorragia per il sangue che prendi
cola dell'emorragia
ok ok se ne sta morendo tantissimo non
c'è deng al cuore signore chi glielo ha
fatto una siringa di sangue nuovo
scelgo dare che noi abbiamo un computer
per una piazza sappiamo niente però
andiamo sulla fiducia che mancano se lo
stomaco cosa era l'altro lo stamattina
il cuore non me lo mette aspetta che
devo rivedere per il vero bisogna
rivedere a che punto siamo
era vedo che il cuore già poverino ma
come no e non riesco ammirare ok adesso
glielo rinvia fermo pop
ok va bene ok cuore il cuore giunto
molto manca manca quel pezzo lì che non
so cosa sia ma fammi vedere che è quel
pikachu questo pikachu qua questo
pikachu vicino al casotto il cuore
questo dame il bisturi lo prendo mai
prende col bisturi guarda garavano poi
ti faccio vedere quale guarda e aspetta
andrà benissimo non morirà mai bob no
perché parlava imprendito
ecco la destra eccola è quello sotto il
cuore con la destra di questo ma
quell'uomo chiaro il lupo chiaro quello
chiaro no quello è di vita
basta sangue sangue non c'è più niente
abbiamo fatto adesso vado a prenderlo
vieni questo e quello nuovo
ma è bravo i fatti fatto bravo ragazzo a
posto perché l'ha messo già sostituito
bravi giusto la messa serale sapere in
tempo quindi a posto io credo che
abbiamo più ucciso che abbiamo più
ucciso si va bene chi se ne frega a noi
ci hanno chiesto di sostituire quelli ci
penserà qualcun altro arresto ciao
e stato bello gioco veramente che non ha
un senso quindi direi che ragazzi va
bene per oggi basta
e stato emozionante questo gioco
meraviglioso
spero ragazzi che il video vi sia
piaciuto regal steve bene continua anche
sul loro canale perché facciamo episodi
alternati niente come stesso ragazzi
lasciato un commento su cosa pensate
nell'operazione in magnifica che abbiamo
fatto sono sapersi schede e non è come
sempre
chiudiamo bene
[Musica]